you
[Music]
well it is my pleasure today to
introduce to you dr. Stephen Schuler who
I told him I was going to introduce him
as a friend of the family because he is
actually way back when we started with
pop therapy he was really influential in
helping Pablo Preeti's design his
interventions I remember Paulo being on
the phone with you for hours talking
about how to design real psychological
interventions that people would actually
use so he's here but he's here from the
University of Northwestern Northwestern
University from the department of
preventive medicine and the Center for
behavioral intervention technologies or
they call it C bit he's also a director
of a remind me the name of a cyber guide
right which is a super useful tool the
thing that's interesting about Steven is
he really works on making mental health
and well-being interventions accessible
and universally available to all which
we love here so I'm sure he'll tell you
all about that today thank you for
coming
Mary Sutton my name is Steven Schuler
I'm in the Department of preventive
medicine at Northwestern University and
I'm trained as a clinical psychologist
and a lot of the work that I do right
now lays at the intersection of sort of
three fields clinical psychology a
design and human-computer interaction
and implementation science and so one of
the questions that really drives me now
is there's been a lot of evidence that
shows that technology-based mental
health can be useful but it really
hasn't caught on despite this rampant
enthusiasm for developing these sorts of
things and so really I think that we as
a field need to consider how can we make
sure that the stuff that we develop
actually gets used in places where it
can be helpful for people so I'm gonna
go through some examples of some of the
work that I'm doing that kind of spans
different ways of thinking about how to
get technologies out there how to
evaluate technologies how to build
technologies for diverse groups and
conclude with some thoughts about you
know the the future of sort of mobile
mental health um so again I'm a clinical
psychologist I imagine and I know most
of the people here at Microsoft are not
clinical psychologists and so I want to
talk a little bit about the scope of the
problem but then also how I think more
about sort of mental health
it applies more broadly so um I work
mostly in the area of depression
depression is a very wide spread problem
so depression is actually the largest
contributor to a disability
approximately one in five folks in the
United States will experience a mental
health disorder um so by that I mean a
clinically diagnoseable version of a
mental health condition so depression
anxiety are the most common but you know
also more serious mental illness like
schizophrenia bipolar disorder these
things are you know just extremely
prevalent it's not you know you know one
in five doesn't means it's not like
someone you know somewhere in your
social network has a mental disorder
this means that you know the people that
you interact with on a daily basis the
people who are intimately involved in
your life experience mental health
issues the other thing I want to kind of
point out in this figure over here is
that you know mental health is not just
about presence or absence of disorders
but it's also continuum of functioning
so I think this is sort of a good
representation that you know we think
usually when we think about sort of
mental health disorders we think about
you know disorders versus everything
else but everyone experiences times in
their life where they experience some
degree of mental health challenge what
this kind of yellow box here is reacting
so reacting means like something's going
on in your life I actually I have two
year-old triplets I can tell you that
when those kids were born it was a very
stressful time my mental health was not
the best state at that time didn't mean
I had a mental health disorder that
meant you know I was experiencing a time
in my life that was stressful I wasn't
sleeping as well you know wasn't eating
as well wasn't being as active you know
all these things that kind of promote
mental health and so that's also
something that we need to address as
mental health professionals and as folks
who are interested in promoting mental
health to acknowledge that the stressors
that come up in our lives and how we
react to those are also things that we
can develop tools and resources to help
people so it's not just am i healthy or
am i you know I do have a mental
disorder but all these sort of steps
along that line so I have this quote
here from the former US Surgeon General
um there's no health without mental
health and what I often say is it's not
just one in five them you know
have a mental health disorder a hundred
percent of Americans have to deal with
mental health this is something that we
should be thinking about this on the
other hand is a very depressing figure
for me so what this figure shows is the
representation of licensed psychologists
this is only psychologists but if I
showed you any other sort of figure that
was a representation of mental health
professionals it would look about the
same so there's about one hundred and
ninety six thousand licensed clinical
psychologist in the u.s. 33 percent of
us counties have not one single licensed
mental health professional so in the red
you see places where there's a very high
concentration of mental health
professionals so if you live on the
coast either coasts if you live in kind
of Chicago area you can probably find a
clinical psychologist if you live
anywhere else you're gonna be in trouble
and if you live in sort of this big
stretch of the country here that's where
we have a you know real sort of dearth
of professionals so there's lots of
places where you don't have the choice
to even get professional mental health
services if you want them and so this is
a big problem that I think technology
has a potential to kind of overcome so
of course there's not for everything we
know this and there's been rapid
development of mental health apps so
this is kind of based off a report from
the ims Institute that came out in 2015
I mean I know that's a little outdated
now I'll say that when they did the same
report in 2013 they estimated there were
about a hundred thousand mental health
apps so from 2013 to 2015 it jumped by
nearly 50 a little bit more than 50% so
they estimated in 2015 that there were
roughly 165 thousand health apps that
are out there there's a more recent
report from a different Institute I saw
that estimated about 250,000 which would
be keeping up with about the rate of
development that we've seen there about
roughly 12,000 of those are focused
towards mental health that's a ton of
stuff that's out there we don't know you
know how good all these things are we
don't know how helpful they are but
there's a lot of different things
that are purported to be able to help
people for different mental health
disorders here's just a little bit of
review of looking at the scientific
evidence behind those things these come
from two separate systematic reviews
where what the authors did in both of
these papers is they looked at all the
apps that were publicly available on the
App Store's focused on a particular
problem so the top one focuses on
depression this lower one focuses on
anxiety the findings are relatively
similar in that you know for depression
they found 117 apps for anxiety they
found 316 about 10% of those were
consistent with evidence-based practices
and by that I mean they went to the
content of the applications they looked
what was in there and they saw does this
coincide with what someone would
recommend people to do from sort of
evidence-based psychological practices
it's about 10% in time those apps are
actually consistent they're actually in
several reviews we find that there's a
lot of apps that even have maybe harmful
content there's one that's cited pretty
regularly for a bipolar disorder where
it tells you if your moods are kind of
getting more disruptive you know this
mood swings are very common bipolar you
might try to help it by drinking more
because that will you know depress your
moods and it's this this information is
out there and it's you know if it's you
know it's these apps are sort of useless
at best sometimes and harmful at the
worst and so we really need a lot more
resources and efforts to try to be able
to provide useful information to
consumers about what mental health apps
are out there which ones might be useful
which ones might be good this sort of
typical way we think about evaluating
things and in medicine and clinical
psychology is through sort of a gold
standard randomized control trial you
know where we have random assignment to
two different programs you would do a
pretest you do the program you do a
post-test this is really great but
unfortunately to do sort of the size of
trials that we typically think about in
clinical psychology as what we would
want and these gold standard
measurements this is a extremely slow
process and so I'm not saying that we
shouldn't
evaluate some things the randomized
controlled trials but I also think that
in the context of digital mental health
we have to think about other evaluation
strategies that can supplement the
information we gain from randomized
control trials so as Mary mentioned I am
the executive director of a project
called cyber guide the goal at cyber
guide is to identify curate and
disseminate information about mental
health apps we're funded by the one mind
Institute which is a nonprofit that
promotes mental health research and we
try to provide you know unbiased
information kind of like the consumer
reports of digital mental health so what
does the cyber guide website look like
what sort of things do we provide for
folks we try to organize different
mental health apps around different
disorder categories ranging from mood
disorders things like depression
schizophrenia serious mental illness
PTSD and other anxiety disorders and as
well as sort of general wellness tools
made to promote mental health sort of
more generally we divide things up also
by the type of strategy that they have
I'll say that most of the tools in the
area of serve depression anxiety tend to
be cognitive behavioral therapy based
this is the strongest that well I should
say this is the treatment with the
strongest evidence base in clinical
psychology does not necessarily mean
that it's the strongest treatment it
means that it's the most easily it's the
most manualized treatment so that I mean
that we as clinical psychologists is
kind of laid down if you want to do
cognitive behavioral therapy this is how
you do it
this is what your sessions could cover
these are the tools that you need and so
it's been subjected to the most of these
randomized control trials so I'm not
saying it's the only thing that works
but I'm saying that it's the thing with
the most evidence that shows that it
works we also have a lot of symptom
trackers these are very popular I'll
talk about later
a lot of mindfulness tools I'll say just
as sort of a point of what people are
interested in mobile mental health on
the cyber guide website besides our main
page in our product guide which
obviously have the most views because
that's where people
can I go through the site the most
popular piece of content on our site is
the review we post of headspace
headspace is an extremely popular mental
health app it has I think an estimated
10 million people who've used it the
founder of headspace his TED talk is 7
million views like people really really
like headspace whether again that means
it's the best mental health app out
there I think that's you know debatable
I've personally you know I've used
headspace it doesn't really capture you
know me but I'm also not really a strong
you know meditator but it's one that's
extremely popular with people um so if
you click on our product guide you'll
see a listing of different mental health
apps we list three different ratings on
our website right now
one is the cyber guide rating which is a
measure of credibility through the cyber
guide rating we look at sort of the
evidence base is there scientific
evidence that suggests that this mental
health app is useful um is it created by
a scientific team or does it have
scientific or clinical advisor support
that would suggest that these are people
who know how to create and design
effective clinical interventions is it
updated frequently but you know does it
have support behind the product is it
coming from a non-profit or is it coming
from a for-profit organization the next
thing we look at is using something
called the mobile operating scale this
is a measure that was developed from
folks out of the University of
Queensland to evaluate health ops
it focuses a lot of like the usability
and user experience so it could be that
there's an app that has very good
credibility but is very hard to use I
think we see this a lot because often
times in scientific studies to get
people to use apps or to get on people
to participate in the study they're
incentivized through financial
incentives there might be a lot of sort
of education on how to use that app in
that randomized control trial so that
means if people are really motivated to
use this and they get a lot of sort of
troubleshooting around it they'll use it
and they can benefit but have you put it
out there and you know you don't have
that support people might have a hard
time using it so I think that again you
kind of need both of these things to
make a really useful application I'm
sure I'm preaching the choir here that
you know
effectiveness usefulness is not just
does it work but you know can people use
it but this is an important piece that's
usually left out in a lot of the
psychological discussion from the
clinical psychology background of these
tools and then lastly we have expert
reviews for some of these apps which is
we have an expert in the field who knows
that content area that's cognitive
behavioral therapy app for depression
you might have a depression
I'm expert if it's mindfulness up we
might have a mindfulness expert but they
create more of a narrative for users
about how you might use this app how it
might be able to benefit you so just a
little bit of discussion around what
we've found from mental health apps um
through this um endeavor of rating them
from cyber guide ratings we rate
everything on a fourteen point scale and
then present everything as a percentage
so apps can range from zero to a hundred
hypothetically or actual range is
fourteen to 93% with an average of 52%
so you know there's some apps that look
really credible out there there's some
apps that look really bad it's cyber
guide we try to not just rate the good
apps because we feel if someone finds an
app we want them to know you know if
they find brain HQ we want them to know
like is this a good app is this not a
good app and so we really try to shy
away from a strategy of identifying and
recommending specific apps our goal is
really to put the information out there
in a useful way for consumers so you can
see from the percentiles that it does
look like a lot of the apps do pretty
well on this credibility rating um well
a lot of apps I should say cluster on
the center in terms of credibility
rating so there's not a lot at this high
end there's not a lot at this low end
there's a lot of apps that you know
there's some it might be useful we don't
really know for the Mars ratings sixty
percent of our products have these Mars
ratings every product listed has a cyber
guide rating the range here again is one
point six three to four point seven five
with average of three point five so
things do okay
this user rating scale again the
interquartile range that shows that a
lot of stuff kind of clusters in the
middle there I'll say that these
credibility and these Mars rating scales
are almost not correlated at all so the
correlation between these things are
about an art of point to you and I say
like not correlate at all because
practically anything you correlate in
psychology will get an art of like point
two like it just happens like things are
somewhat correlated they also don't
correlate very highly with the ratings
off of the public app stores um neither
the Mars rating nor the cyber guide
rating so it seems like if we just look
at the the user ratings of scores that
that's not really representing either
the credibility or the user experience
of now so it's hard to say then from a
user's perspective when they go and rate
these applications on App Store's what
they're actually looking at i'm also say
in terms of public facing app store
ratings
um so things off to the google play
store in the apple itunes store there's
a lot of these applications that are
very popular in either the clinical
literature or the popular literature
that have no public sort of rating of on
the app stores because they don't have
enough ratings that at least on the
itunes store you need a couple you need
a certain number of rings before i'll
actually display the average and usually
most of these mental health apps don't
have them i think about 10 percent of
the apps that we've looked at actually
have publicly available ratings on the
app stores in terms of the expert
reviews about 30 percent of our products
have expert reviews and we so the expert
reviews do look at the higher range of
the product so we have a a verge cyber
guide rating of 60 and then average Mars
rating of three point seven nine so
again we try to focus on the upper range
of products there we don't really feel
like we need to provide consumers with a
lot of information about how to use the
products that we don't seem to be all
that good we really want to direct
people to things that we think might be
more useful so one of the things
actually we'd like to do more in the
future
with cyber guide is we want to look more
also at integrating the user experience
of their
impression of these applications as I
said the the public consumer
marketplaces of app stores that those
ratings don't really relate to the
information that we're gathering and so
we'd like to gain more understanding of
you know what it is that people like and
don't like about applications and how we
can present that back to them so that's
one thing that we're really kind of
focusing on now is how do we engage the
consumers as stakeholders in terms of
contribute contributing information that
we can then disseminate I think this is
a really big need for mental digital
mental health more generally as engaging
stakeholders more in the process of both
the development and the evaluation piece
of this yeah the FDA does not currently
regulate any of these mental health apps
the FDA only regulates health apps if
they are used for the purposes of
assessment of providing an intervention
so if you were if you developed an app
that was meant to sort of diagnose you
for a mental disorder and then provide
that information in your clinician it
would be arguable that that would be you
know should be regulated by the FDA
these apps are really sold as sort of
do-it-yourself for self management tools
and so they don't fall under the FDA
regulation there is one app I know that
was on track for FDA approval and that
was an app that was created by pair
therapeutics that was made to be used in
the context of substance use but that
was one again that helped diagnose
people and then provided that
information to their provider so it
really has to be to be under the current
sort of FDA purview of what they've said
they're gonna regulate in digital health
space it needs to be used in the context
of treatment is there any way of
reporting errors
so does anybody track these you know no
not in sort of the public space I think
that's and that's one thing I think is
also really important is where the like
this bipolar app I mentioned that you
know has this very sort of potentially
dangerous recommendation in there and I
think again it's a right now it's a very
sort of Wild West and that would be a
good you know thing to kind of get it's
like collecting more information about
when these apps do you go we get
seriously wrong by APA you mean the
American Psychological Association
American Psychiatric Association so the
American Psychiatric Association does
have an app rating system it follows a
lot of the same kind of guidelines of
what we do in cyber guide it's meant
more to be a consumer framework so what
the American Psychiatric Association has
done is it sets up sort of a tiered
system of if you're a consumer and you
want to look at the mental health app
these are the things you could should
consider privacy and security
effectiveness user experience
interoperability I think that's really
great but I think as a consumer I would
have liked if you told me about you know
if I went to go buy a car and you told
me like these are the things you should
consider when you're buying a car safety
gas mileage you know all these things
you can tell me the evaluate those
things but I'm not going to know how to
do it and so I think that's a little bit
of where I think that the American
Psychiatric Association framework does a
really nice job of like saying what we
should look at but I think that
consumers often need that sort of extra
step to get there a lot of the sort of
areas that we cover overlap with the
American Psychiatric Association with
the exception of the privacy secure
security section that's something we're
debating a lot internally as sort of a
so there wasn't or a group that tried to
evaluate health apps more generally
known as haptic and haptic got in big
trouble because they had a model where
they would do individual sort of
certification of apps I'm kind of like
you would want the FDA to do perhaps and
they got into hot water when there are a
couple apps that they sort of signed off
on
and was shown that they were actually
selling um users data to third parties
and so I think that's one of the
problems that you run into with this
privacy and security is that you it's
hard to know sometimes with these apps
where the data actually is going what
people are doing with data and some
organizations are not so clear with that
and so again it's hard to provide sort
of recommendation of like this is a
secure app if you don't have all the
information from yourself if I'm in the
App Store and I'm looking for anxiety
app how would I even know that Cyberdyne
existed that's a great question I think
that that's one thing that we are trying
to do is partner with organizations we
have a agreement with Mental Health
America to partner with their screening
exercise where people get screened
through Mental Health America and then
get recommend get recommendations for
different services you know right now
there's no way of knowing that and I
think without teaming with those app
stores themselves um that's going to be
a problem that up is not going to be
able to be overcome
um so I want to transition to a little
bit more research around how and why
people use mental health apps um this is
a Penny Arcade comic that I really like
that makes me think about this from
years ago where an apps were really just
blowing up and the two characters are
fighting about whether one should buy a
console game or app games and I love
this quote here like will you buy one
3ds game a Nintendo game and I'll buy 40
games on my phone and we'll see who has
more fun so sort of this idea of like
yeah you can support in 40 dollars on
one game where I can spend 40 dollars
and 40 different games and we'll see who
actually gets more enjoyment out of this
kind of arguing for this model of
diversity in terms of bombing projects
so um one of the things that we did
recently is we looked at users who were
entering into or are interested in
entering into different clinical trials
that we were doing at the Center for
behavioral intervention technologies and
before they got unboard and into any of
our trials we actually just simply asked
them you know what sort of health apps
you have on your phone what sort of
mental health apps do you have on your
phone why do you use these apps on what
are the apt names and we found that most
people use mental how multiple apps
the average was 2 there's a range from 0
to 20 so again this isn't suggesting
that people are finding one health app
and they're using it they're using this
you know this penny arcade a sort of
model of you know trying a bunch of
different things and seeing what's
helpful for them about 1/4 of them where
mental health or wellness apps which
corresponds you know somewhat with the
sort of overall representation again
probably this number is a bit elevated
from the general population because
these are all people who are entering
into a clinical trial that was focused
on mental health ninety two point eight
percent were free and it's worth knowing
that this is not representative of the
overall sort of marketplace and mental
health app so people are
disproportionately focused on
downloading free apps for their health
which i think is really interesting and
also you know again not representative
if you just look at the sort of the
marketplace review of what's out there
and in our data we found if we looked at
the purposes for the applications the
most common reason people said they were
using mental health applications was for
tracking purposes about 40 percent of
the apps that people were using they
said they were using for some sort of
tracking purpose it was really
interesting to me actually it was that
when we looked at the names of the
different apps that people were using
there was not a large proportion but
there was a proportion of apps that they
noted that were not mental health ops
they were not health apps at all and
they were things like snapchat like
Google Documents like Facebook like
Twitter and people actually reported
using these different things for health
purposes and so I think that's another
sort of interesting piece to this puzzle
here that as you know clinical
psychologists we often look at the app
store we look at things the you know
people search for anxiety people search
for depression and those are the things
we're kind of evaluating but there's a
lot of way that people might be using
non health apps for health purposes and
I think that we as a field should better
understand when that's going on what
people are getting out of that and how
we can actually maybe
some of these tools to better meet the
mental health needs that people are
having when they're going to these
different things so I want to kind of
loop back to that IMS report because I
think it actually has some interesting
points to make about what the apps
actually do in terms of functionality so
if back in 2015 when the IMS looked at
all the different health apps that are
available they noticed that about half
the apps had a single functionality so
that means that most of the apps do one
thing and that most of the time that
functionality was to inform people so
effectively most health apps that are
out there are psycho-educational tools
that teach people things
there's Self Help books that have been
made into an app format self-help books
are great we've had them for years they
can be useful for people but I think
what's going on here is a sad
opportunity a lost opportunity I should
say to use the true sort of affordances
of digital technologies to do really
sort of creative things in the health
space there's I think it was about 5%
here of apps that were used for
communication purposes so the ability to
connect people either to each other and
that was actually what was most common
is that so of that small percentage of
apps that have communication purposes
most of the time those apps are allowing
people to connect to social media maybe
that's the best thing for health apps to
do maybe it's not I'm not gonna you know
open up the debate here but I'm just
saying like that's the most common
communication purposes let's share our
health information to social media 34
were just social networks again sort of
a social you know component to that 2%
were to providers so very few health
apps actually have any sort of
information of interoperability it
allows information to be translated from
a user to provider um again I think this
is a big missed opportunity I was
talking with Mary a little bit about
this earlier about how we actually can
take information from different health
apps and be able to share that with
providers and I think we need a lot more
understanding of what providers want and
those circumstances what patients want
in those circumstances and how to best
sort of translate patient needs
wants to provider needs it once someone
is oh go ahead
let's curious if a 2% for a provider
communication is that real ladies who
just not right building that in
functionality into the app to begin with
because they don't want to or is it
because of EHR barrier integration
integration barriers uh that's a good
question I think it's probably a little
bit of both
I mean giving information to the EHR is
a huge headache I know at Northwestern
we're just starting this new initiative
called oh man it's like project one or
something like that we're chart they're
trying to bring all of the instances of
epic to have one version where they'll
all communicate with each other and in
the process of doing that they've
completely locked down introduction of
new information to the EHR so we can't
put any information it's just whenever I
do projects that is a non-starter no
information gets going to the EHR I've
seen some workarounds where it's like
information can be translated into a
document that can be uploaded as a
attachment to a provider no message but
direct integration of the EHR has been a
major headache for people to you know we
didn't look in that specific study we
have a current study where we're doing
or we're trying to ask that question to
find more like you know where'd you come
to health apps and also what we're
really interested in the current study
we're doing is when they look for them
what information would be most valuable
to them to kind of direct their
decisions I think that's you know it's a
big open question yeah I think it's
worth looking to providers the choir is
actually doing or is it still like you
said that's where you have to I that's a
tricky question and maybe can I come
back to that being never talked in it
because I think you know there might be
a little bit more discussion to have her
on that but that's a really good and
tricky question so I want to actually go
into another platform that we've
developed it in northwestern that we
call in telecare and it takes a slightly
different design perspective to a mobile
mental health so what in telecare is
instead of a single app we developed an
app suite that's organized by this hub
application so the entire app suite
actually has 12 different mini
applications that each focus on a
specific behavior change technique um so
here's a couple of them this is actually
one of the most popular apps it's called
daily feats when you sign up for the app
you take a brief sort of depression
anxiety screener
I'll say entelechy err it was
intentionally designed to deal with
issues of depression anxiety so you take
a depression anxiety screener it gives
you a set of tasks to do each day a
daily you know daily feats they're
organized around your level of
depression anxiety um so if you're if
you are pretty depressed when you start
out you'll have just very basic feet so
get out of bed groom yourself make good
food choices go outside I will say these
might seem very basic to you but one of
the things the feedback we've gotten
from our users is that it's extremely
empowering for them when they're
seriously depressed for us to kind of
reframe these things that they truly
struggle with as beets to be
accomplished so you open up the
application you check off which things
you do that day if you form a streak
over multiple days you get a little
indication in terms of you know green
numbers you have enough streaks over
subsequent days you move up to
subsequent levels and you continue to
keep leveling up getting more and more
challenging things very simple
application very easy to use very very
popular suite this isn't five days of
completing a goal this is an app that I
developed it's called my mantra I call
it the Pinterest of cognitive behavioral
therapy you collect sort of pictures
that organized around a positive self
forming mantra um there's a couple
example ones in here and the the
application things like I'm strong I'm
grateful I'm resilient and as you
collect these you know these photos you
get them fed back to you through
notifications again very very simple a
popular app within our suite this is
thought challenger it's maybe the most
kind of classic mental health app that's
in the entelechy suite
it helps walk you through the process of
cognitive restructuring which is this
idea that
the the content of your thoughts is more
important than the actual situation it
helps you come up with more sort of
positive ways to view situations so you
come up with a negative unrealistic spot
you substitute it with a more realistic
way of thinking this walks you through
the step five step process of doing it
and on the home screen you have all of
the kind of good positive reframe
thoughts a word cloud that's generated
from that content we want to throw the
positive content back at people as
opposed to the negative content so we
did a eight-week field trial of the
IntelliJ platform I will say that it was
done along with sort of coached support
we had a person providing some light
sort of encouragement engagement through
text messaging this is the result from
that single arm field trial we found
that people over eight weeks experienced
significant reductions in their levels
of depression as well as anxiety we just
recently wrapped up a 300 person
forearmed randomized controlled trial of
and telecare so we'll have more data on
this soon this again shows you know
similar thing but looks at the percent
of people who are in full remission or
partial or sorry for remission or
recovery which is indicated by sort of
clinically set cut points in terms of
reductions on those same scales so
people reduced in their depression
anxiety this was actually one of the
more exciting um findings to me which is
that the use of in telecare was pretty
consistent over that eight-week period
so we had an average launch of about 25
sessions per week in an average time of
one minute per session so people really
were going to these apps multiple times
per day using them in very short bursts
and that that use was sustained over the
say week period in most mental health
apps you see a pattern where people
might use it for a week or two and that
drops off dramatically they call this
the law of attrition in digital health
research that it's pretty inevitable
that people will stop using these things
over time so at least this was sort of
good evidence that in
again it's a coach trial so there is a
human supporter there on this isn't
people who are just using things on
their own
we've done some evaluations of unco CH
and it's not you know as good as this
but it still looks fairly good in the
intelecom suite so this is just another
thing about I'm treatment engagement the
thing I think I want to point out here
is that the average time that people
that the coaches used was 39 minutes
over those eight weeks so again this is
a very sort of lean protocol that these
coaches are doing this is not you know
full sort of therapy that's done through
text messaging it's you know about three
text messages per week that are sent to
the user to sort of encourage them to
continue to use the platform yeah so
there's some notifications through the
the apps it's organized by we have a hub
app that actually provides messaging and
so all those notifications hit the the
central hub so they're all kind of
contained within the app another thing
actually within that hub app is one
thing that we're really interested in is
if we can use this in telecare platform
as a recommendation engine and so one of
the arms in that so I'll say that
forearm field trial is a two by two
design um so we compared coaching versus
no coaching and we compared a full intel
hair hub app that had notifications and
recommendations so every week you would
get a new recommendation as it says this
week try out these two and telecare apps
for you
versus an intel care app a hub app that
just had then the sort of available and
telecare apps within that hub so no
notifications and no recommendations so
one of the things that we're really
interested in is can we actually take
these apps and then figure out which you
know apps should a person use in the
next week so this is just a little
representation of what that and telecare
hub looks like this is the the non
recommending version of the hub app so
in the recommending version you'll have
a little box here that'll say these are
the two apps you should use this week so
right now it looks like initial data
suggesting that
we're actually able to increase use of
the applications through these
recommendations and that this specific
recommendation that the recommendation
engine is that we're using is actually
improving on a naive recommender that's
just giving random recommendations so it
does seem like we're able to do a little
bit of this recommendation but I think
this is something where we have a lot of
kind of room to improve in our platform
yeah
I recommend the city are you I mean
obviously you're recommending
prescribing them to use this yeah and
that other arm when you just gave them
coached or non coached they get to
choose which choice yeah yeah exactly
even in the recommended one they can use
other apps too so it's not that those
are the only ones available to them
we're just pushing them towards
particular ones and we do these apps are
all freely available in the Google Play
Store a couple of them are in iOS and
we've either got I think we've got three
to five that are on iOS already I know
the development is kind of rolling out
for all of the iOS ones we do find that
people from the public store who
download the hub tend to download more
applications than people who don't
download the hub too so this hub points
people the things that they wouldn't be
finding otherwise just looking at and
telecare absurd and generally from the
Play Store support from health care
provider and recommender kind of
influencing so we have not tested it
within a health care system yet that's a
project we have on the horizon is
actually doing this in healthcare
settings where your providers are a
member of your provider team would be
you know that supporter so far our
supporters have we start out with
clinical psychologists from our group we
move to research assistance because as I
said we're not doing very fancy stuff
with the recommendations here and I mean
one thing we're also really interested
in is if we could automate some of those
recommendations there using natural
language processing because at least our
reports from the the people doing the
support is that it's not what they're
doing is not stuff that is all that
challenging but yeah I think these are a
lot of open questions we have with how
we might be able to use this
so I want to move on to another sort of
pilot study that we've been working on
in Chicago aimed at providing mental
health resources to homeless youth so
about every year about two million folks
ages kind of 18 through 24 will spend a
night homeless and the rates of mental
health disorders and homeless
individuals are about two to three times
higher than the general population at
the same time only about 10 percent of
those folks get any sort of access to
mental health resources so we have a
population highly vulnerable population
huge sort of need for mental health
source services very little sort of
availability um so what we've done in
Chicago is we launched a project that we
call stepping stone I'm stepping stone
has a couple different components I'm
first every youth who signs up for our
study we give them a smartphone device
that's theirs to keep and we pay for six
months of their data service it's just
it's one thing that we've been we feel
very strongly is that you know keeping
them connected to having technology as a
resource is you know very beneficial for
them this has been an interesting
challenge we've learned a lot of sort of
interesting things around so we give
them a data plan of 5 gigabytes they get
throttled if they go above that we had
one period where our provider was
switching over carriers and that froggen
was turned off we had a youth that used
120 gigabytes of data in one week it was
crazy I mean they you know they're never
on Wi-Fi they're using this as their
entertainment as their communication as
everything it's it's been a very
interesting learning experience in
addition we put three applications on
their phone we use two of those and
telecare apps one focused on meditation
mindfulness called purple chill another
one focused on sleep I Ching sleep
hygiene called om slumber time we have a
daily survey app on their application on
their phone called pocket helper it
sends a survey that asks them about what
their biggest challenge was that day
what's their stress level like what was
their sleep quality like and it feeds
that information back to a therapist on
our team
on that therapist they set up three
30-minute phone calls that focus around
kind of general coping skills they also
have the opportunity of text message
that therapists at times outside of
those phone calls that's one reason why
we're collecting this daily survey
information so that if they text or call
the therapist have outside of their
scheduled sessions of the therapist
there's a little bit more about what's
going on in their life and that's that's
what the the project consists of this is
what sort of that daily survey looks
like it gives them a coping kind of tip
every day that they rate on a five-point
scale
I think feeds back their survey data to
them and we ask them kind of those brief
questions so this is sort of the general
model we have a back-end dashboard that
provides that information to the
clinician the question gets that
information and they're able to
intervene if something comes up to send
in kind of text message support in the
moment or as close to the moment as
possible I mean the the youth are able
to text back to the nervous so we've run
this project now with about I think we
have now about forty people who've been
recruited most people really like the
study um they like the tips the best
they like the apps the least um this is
something that's been really interesting
to us because the tips are really easy
for us to develop the apps are very
expensive and hard and so it makes me
wonder sometimes like why are we
building up why don't we just send tips
to people it's a good question
most people would recommend the study
for other people we haven't looked at
the clinical outcomes yet but we've had
sort of encouraging results from the
engagement actually initially our
engagement looks really bimodal
people would either engage in everything
that would complete all their sessions
they were text message regularly or they
would kind of disappear completely we've
actually recently sort of had one more
sort of bucket of engagement so we have
the people who don't engage at all we
have the people who complete all their
phone sessions and text message
regularly and now we have a group of
folks who aren't completing any of the
phone sessions but they're texting
regularly with the therapist so it seems
like you know there's different ways to
engage people in these platforms I think
that that's an important
thing to remember is like what is the
expected use and also what are patterns
of engagement that might be interesting
and useful for the person doing it but I
think a lot of time when we look at
digital mental health people think about
adherence um
they use that word a lot and I I'm a
little skittish with the word adherence
because adherence kind of suggests to me
that there's one way of interacting it's
like we have a medication you're
supposed to use it three times a day and
like I don't know if digital mental
health is the same sort of way so I
really like to think about this as sort
of engagement or usage but there's
different ways that people might engage
with the platform and that doesn't mean
that one way is you know necessarily the
best way or you know we shouldn't
preference one style engagement besides
the other I think we need to learn more
about what styles of engagement are
useful for different folks like
absolutely you know I think one of the
reasons is that it's not they weren't
well integrated into the program that we
had I also think that the sleep app we
put on there because that was one of our
sort of first goals for this project was
to work with sleep hygiene and the kids
are actually not all that interested in
sleep hygiene there's a lot of other
things that they have going on I think
there are problems with depression
anxiety also slightly different than in
general population so there's a lot of
sort of emotional regulation and in your
personal issues that come up those are
the main content that kind of came up in
the text messages and the phone sessions
and we don't have apps that kind of
specifically address those things and so
even though the sort of treatments like
cognitive behavioral therapy would still
be a treatment strategy that would be
useful we might need to develop apps
that kind of focus on the specific
content areas that would be interesting
to this group so I think you know
tailoring for a particular population is
sort of really you know key and critical
so one was because our funder was
finding us to do sort of sleep stuff and
so we put the sleep app on there we're
always tied a little bit by you know
where our money is coming from and then
the the mindfulness app we put on there
because it reinforced a lot of the
coping skills that we were teaching in
our and those fun sessions I think I
mean that's actually something we're
moving to a phase two project here and
in the phase 2 project we're putting
more diversity of apps on there because
you know we have the apps available to
us in the healthcare suite
might make sense just to give them all
to them and see which ones they use so
here's actually I want to conclude real
fast with a kind of conceptual thing
that I talked a lot about in my work
that I think I want to frame a little
bit differently here because uh you know
being here at Microsoft I know that this
might be a term that some people are
familiar with and I use it slightly
differently than its used comminuted
literature so the term skeuomorphism is
a term that's used a lot in like UI UX
design to talk about visual elements
that exist in digital technologies that
are sort of remnants of the past
physical examples of that so you know I
use this example here of light bulbs
that look like candle flames because
that's what candles look like in the
past those things could be anything that
could be dinosaurs they could be hockey
pucks but we decided to make them
candles to look like fire this is a you
know great example I got from a
presentation where someone says I showed
my twelve-year-old son an old floppy
disk and said wow cool you 3d printed
the Save icon no that's the opposite way
that works
we made a save icon that represented the
way that we used to save things so I
think that often in digital mental
health we actually engage in conceptual
scale morphisms where we take concepts
from face-to-face therapy and we
translate them to digital technologies
so we make web-based cognitive
behavioral therapy programs where we
expect people to come back on a weekly
basis and spend you know 50 minutes
going through content because that's
what psychotherapy is like when that's
not the way that most people use digital
technology and that maybe is not the way
that we most helpful to them so
effectively we are trying to fit you
know our old model of psychological
practice into these digital mediums and
I think instead what we should be doing
is we think about digital mental health
is sort of reimagining how we can
actually take unique affordances of
technologies to build new products new
designs that actually leverage what we
know about behavior change in mental
health strategies but do so in sort of
the new medium of technology so here's
actually a project that I did with Lonny
Roche from University of Minnesota where
we were sort of very interested in this
stakeholder engaged
spective around happiness technologies
so we did a six week
sorry yeah six week cooperative inquiry
sort of co.design workshop with kids
around happiness technologies so this
was a true sort of interdisciplinary
project I came in as the clinical
psychologist with a background in
positive psychology we spent the first
couple weeks of the workshop teaching
kids about the inventing process and
also teaching them positive psychology
skills so I did what you know I would
typically do as a psychologist if I was
running just a psychology workshop and
then we transitioned to okay now that
we've empowered you with the concepts
and the knowledge of positive psychology
we taught you about gratitude we taught
you about mindfulness we talked you
about sort of problem-solving from a
cognitive perspective what sort of
technologies would you guys build that
would able be able to promote well-being
and they came up with some really sort
of interesting examples this is my
favorite one here this is the
mindfulness backpack it had a little
sort of distraction machine on the back
to be able to take people out of
whatever moment they're in it also had a
good smell generator and the kind of
good smells these kids came up with were
chocolate chip cookies and the smell of
their own bed just really sort of cool
creative things um they also came up
with things that were very similar to
some things that have been designed I'm
so this was there I sort of thought
tinct it used fish which i think is kind
of funny because I've seen a lot of sort
of designs from different folks where
they use animals or fish as kind of
representations of mental sort of health
processes in sort of visual displays for
applications but this one is kind of
coming up with a positive cognitive
reframing I'm smart kind of
counteracting some-some negative
thoughts that they had but it was really
sort of interesting engaging and useful
to engage with this process with the
kids I'm another thing I thought that
was really interesting was looking at
the engagement strategies they came up
with with how would you want to entice
kids to stay engaged with these
different technologies we definitely saw
this sort of typical engagement
strategies that come up and what a lot
of feed people design know
games gamification health is huge
although I have a separate rant I'll
tell you another time about my theories
on gamification a social support is big
but actually one of the things I thought
were really interesting were responding
directly to emotions or thoughts making
these things more tangible for people it
was also really interesting if we went
go back to this example here you can see
that most of the things that the kids
came up with were some form of embodied
technology wearables backpacks robots
watches like they really wanted
something that could touch and feel if
you look at the sort of digital mental
health space most of the stuff is
software we have very few sort of
wearable tangible technologies that are
trying to promote mental health
especially in kids I think this is a
space that really would be interesting
to develop so I think that teaming with
kids gave us some interesting ideas
about what are different things that
people would be interested in I think
more of this sort of code design process
needs to be done in digital mental
health again I'm probably preaching to
the choir a little bit here but I think
you know coming from a clinical
psychology background this is typically
not what clinicians do when they develop
sort of new mental health technologies
yeah there was also sort of this I've
actually thought this this was a theme
that was really sort of interesting what
the kids is that there was this
interesting sort of balance between the
positive and the negative and that they
wanted things that sort of identified
the negative experiences that they were
going through and had some ways to try
to incorporate the positive aspect and
so that that's a really sort of
interesting dichotomy that doesn't show
up in sort of more broad sort of
discussion of positive psychology so
again some of these ideas are sort of
off-the-wall I will say that at least in
the iteration process I think that's
something that was sort of unique about
the way that we did this is we did this
sort of long term workshop on there were
14 sessions we did with the same kids
they came back they learned more about
the inventing process the amount of
ideas they generated sort of decreased
over time and the quality of the ideas
tended to get better throughout sessions
so definitely they learned along the way
you know how to engage in this process
with us and I think most of the times
again I'm not I come from a clinical
psychology background I am NOT a
designer even though I love this stuff
but most of the people I see doing sort
of this type of work in psychology tend
to do a workshop with a group of kids
and move on to another workshop with
another group of kids and I think there
is this sort of interesting aspect of
trying to think better on how to team
over the long term with the stakeholders
that were working with because I think
that's a big part of the sort of mental
health journey is like we that it we
design a lot these sort of singular
experiences and or experiences that are
meant to say stable over time and that's
not the way therapy works that's not the
way life works that's not the way mental
health works I think we need to better
think about also how we allow tools to
be flexible to allow for a variety of
different interactions so just a couple
conclusions here there's lots of mint
mobile mental health options that are
out there they're actually being
developed at a breakneck pace you know
every single day it seems like there's
some new app or new product or something
that someone's doing in digital mental
health the diversity of mobile mental
health options is somewhat limited
though a lot of people tend to be
building the same sort of things I have
seen so many cognitive behavioral
therapy thought record apps we built a
cognitive there of behavioral therapy
sort of thought record app and the
quality is unknown and so I think that
one of our goals right now should be to
introduce some more variants some more
diversity into the products the designs
the things we're evaluating and use the
information we have available to us to
better understand which of these things
work and which of these things don't and
then again to kind of go back to the see
my I mentioned at the beginning that
this excitement this enthusiam for
enthusiasm for digital mental health has
not been matched by implementation we
see lots of things that are out there
that have been developed we've not seen
a lot of things that have really caught
on at least in the area of kind of
depression anxiety there's been some
where on the magnitude of a hundred
randomized control trials evaluating
these things there has not been one sort
of successful implementation where these
things have caught on and stayed around
in a health
and I think that one of the big problems
for that is these things have not been
designed with implementation in mind and
haven't really we haven't really deeply
thought about how these things can
integrate into the healthcare systems
that they're in these are just some
examples of sort of recent sort of
designs or different things and mobile
mental health have been rolled out there
and I think one thing that's been really
interesting to me as a observer in this
field is that we see more and more sort
of work where we're seeing these things
pop up in places where we wouldn't we
don't think about these things as a
mental health tool so Facebook's efforts
to try to do suicide identification or
outreach the Google calendars feature to
sort of recommend a goal in times where
we have open spaces in our calendar this
is behavior activation this is something
we've been doing in in clinical
psychology for years and years and years
you get people more active you get
people more engaged and naturally
reinforcing things spending time with
other people being physically active
this will help your mental health and so
I think there's a lot of places where
clinical psychology ideas can be what
could be well implemented and integrated
into existing technologies if it's done
thoughtfully and if it's done usefully
this kind of goes back to the theme I
sort of mentioned with the the paper we
did reviewing different mental health
are different health apps that people
were using where people identified
health uses for non health apps so in
conclusion I just want acknowledge many
of the people who helped me do this work
as well as some of my different funding
organizations that have helped to
support this and I think we have a
little bit of time for questions but I
do want to kind of come back to the
question of sort of integration into
healthcare settings but thank you all
for your attention
[Applause]
sure yeah so uh I think it's a really
tricky thing so there's a project I've
been working on right now where we're
trying were developed a platform that's
made to be used in the context of
clinical behavioral therapy for
depression
sorry conical cognitive behavioral
therapy for depression and we did that
through sort of user turn design with
both patients and providers and those
groups have very different goals and
very different sort of interests and so
I think we need better ways to bring the
information that patients or people
create into the clinical setting in ways
that are useable to clinicians and so
there's a project also another project
I'm working on we're trying to use
Fitbit data in an intensive outpatient
program for veterans with PTSD to try
get information about activity levels
sleep levels that might be able to
inform the treatment but I think what we
really need to do know is what are sort
of the treatment goals that providers
have and how can this information this
data be most useful for the things that
they're accomplishing so I think it's a
it's a design problem but I think it's
one that's surmountable quite a little
bit more dense and like some
cardiovascular health we've been talking
right is there - and a lot of
information that the entire ask your
health is not usable as a fighter but
the patients find it very interesting
whether or not they still dangerous yeah
I think one thing one thing that we've
found in some settings is that it might
be the case that we're gonna have to
create new professions of people who are
gonna be able to deal with that data
because again like the cardiovascular
folks in like you know providers usually
don't have a lot of time um but if you
could have another role sort of
developed that could yet sort of the
information you know collector and you
know presenter like that might be
supposed to be sure maybe health coach
maybe something physician we're driving
to but also the same thing if there is
some way to take off some information in
boil it down to something as useful to a
treatment plan that a physician can
recommend then they have some use for
the data otherwise it becomes you know
just noise to them Waco at well dark
rates you can look at well done no
prescribed a
position - this guy that yeah I don't
think that's an interesting so why don't
you like gamification there's something
huge push I think we did have two points
in there so I think the implication has
to be done very mindfully to not - for
two aspects one that you know if we're
dealing with mental health I think we
want to make sure that we respect that
for uh for many people this is a very
serious very challenging thing and I
don't think we want to necessarily
transform this into a game for them I
think the other sort of aspect I I
borrow a phrase from in bogus that he
talks about chocolate-covered broccoli
is that we uh we know chocolates good we
know broccoli is good for us most of us
are willing to tolerate broccoli because
we know it's good for us even if we
don't love it we love chocolate but you
know you don't want to put those two
things together and so I think
gamification is that sometimes it's like
we know health is good first we know
these things are good
we know games are fun we like to do them
but you don't want to just spread the
games all over the health stuff so I
think that if you one sort of belittle a
person's emotional experience than
context of mental disorders and to make
it more about the extrinsic engagement
in the gaming component as opposed to
the intrinsic value that they get out of
the activity I think that's very
challenging on the same time we know
game mechanics we know challenges you
know that's a big part of sort of mental
health I you know something I say all
the time is that you know one of the
secrets to really getting people you
know hooked into the things that we do
or you know getting people moving the
right direction is uh clear goals and
immediate feedback and that you know
that's a game so I think that we can
integrate gaming elements but the term
gamification like scares me sometimes so
that's my gamification rant
chocolate-covered broccoli yeah I don't
- fair question about a cyber guys how
do you how do you choose which apps you
want to evaluate second is uh you
mentioned that the scores are different
or your cyber greetings and the apps
pervading sighs when I mean what is the
correlation between those ratings so I
think the correlation there is about
0.15 I'd have to look it up again it's
pretty low and that so I answered that
first because it's the easier question
to answer in terms of prioritizing apps
we have sort of a multi-stage
prioritization process we do a
consistent review of the scientific
literature again because we sort of one
of the sort of the rating things on is
credibility we know that things are
going to higher credibility scores if
they're in the scientific literature and
so we're try to sort of promote those we
then do sort of a prioritization based
on a popularity score that's a
combination of the number of downloads
and the reviews from the public stores
as well as sort of identification
through searches and other appearances
and media sources so if people are
talking about it we want to make sure
that it's represented there's an app
that's up there that's not really being
used people aren't talking about it like
it's not as important for us to rate
especially if like we don't have good
evidence that you know has scientific
support or sort of clinical content
behind it so those are sort of the main
factors we use to sort of identify and
to propose them we also get some sort of
self referrals through you know a
developer has designed an application
they wanted rated on cyber guide and so
I think we get you know like depending
on the week like five to ten people
contacting us about like would you post
my thing or would you evaluate this
thing that I've seen out there I think a
lot of times we get things of people
who've like created some sort of
self-help site that has like just
content on it which is not the sort of
stuff we review and we also get a lot of
requests from beats b2b or you know to
business products so platforms are
trying to sell to healthcare settings or
to businesses to provide some sort of
mental health support for their
employees or the the folks that they
cover we currently are not evaluating
those because we're meant to be a more
consumer if they facing website and then
the other reason is that a lot of
businesses and healthcare systems
have the resources to evaluate things
and usually have their sone own sort of
evaluation criteria and so we're really
trying to provide a service for people
who don't have the resources to evaluate
things or again to kind of go back to
the American Psychiatric Association
framework maybe don't know how to
evaluate it themselves even if they're
given a little bit of a framework so
we're trying to create more information
I'm to the people who need it
have a talk starting at 3 so we have to
be out of the room by a quarter to one
more and then we'll so you mentioned
that thought challenger you had very
good results with engagement and usage
over your eight-week trial and you said
you didn't think that the coaching was
all of it yep what's responsible for it
well sorry I don't think the coaching
was on all of the engagement yeah sure
so what what was it about what would I
think one of the reasons is that they
were really designed for very simple
interactions they were meant to be brief
that a lot of these other applications
we see Tim tend to be multi featured so
you'd have the thought challenging piece
in there with an activity scheduling
piece and a logging piece and some
psycho-educational piece and so you have
to really dig into these applications to
get the thing and it's useful and so I
think that sort of simple design of
these applications is actually sort of
useful to kind of increase engagement
and I mean I think that was also shown
through at least the way that people
engage these things kind of quick small
person so I think that was one piece of
it um I also think that because it's an
app suite as opposed to a single
application I think one of the problems
I think that mobile mental health faces
is that you know people when they go
looking for something they're usually
more highly motivated than they're going
to be at other things they might find an
application they may start using in them
it might not work and they might then
decide to stop doing it and you know
they might have a thought like I tried
that digital mental health stuff and it
doesn't work and I think by reframing
this is like an app suite there's a
little bit of a reframe that can happen
that like we know not everything works
for everyone and that's why we've made
out these different options and so if
the one if the first thing you use
doesn't work for you maybe something
within this suite will so what we find
in a lot of other areas of psychology we
have these sort of
multi-modal sort of stuff is that these
kitchen sink approaches work much better
than approaches that have sort of a
single you know piece to it I mean so I
think by sort of unpacking the kitchen
sink and laying out the tools kind of
all separately it kind of helps people
engage with that platform and that's
just sort of my conjecture you know we
don't have a lot of evidence speaking to
that but you know I think that that's a
piece this kind of thing into it but we
need to do more research to figure that
out it's a good question
[Applause]